the Iranian nation and freedom fighters
are mourning this great loss the United
States by assassinating a senior Iranian
general has started a new chapter that
will cause them problems the beginning
of the end of America's presence in the
region has started they do not respect
international law they are attacking
Iranian history which is a shared
heritage to the whole world they have
committed a crime against Iran by
assassinating our important general it
has multi dimensions it has started from
the region in the US will withdraw from
our region but what what we have
committed by attack assassinating on our
general they have violated in breached
our territorial integrity we will make a
decision on when and where to retaliate
well it's a very he was a very solemn
foreign minister today he seems like
he's still in mourning and these
obviously are three days of mourning and
the impact of the assassination of Qasem
Soleimani can't be overstated and on on
Iranians we were out in the streets
yesterday many people still upset now
javad zarif like you said mentioned the
words miscalculation big mistake he said
that it was a cowardice act and what
he's talking about is the impact that
the assassination of Gosselin's of the
money will have not only here in Iran
but on the entire region increasingly we
are hearing voices from Iran that there
will be revenged that there will be a
retaliation and the the the way that the
government and officials and state
authorities here are talking about this
retaliation it'll be difficult to come
back from that we're seeing pictures
from Carmen where Qasem Soleimani will
be buried now the word that we heard
yesterday on the streets in Tehran and
that we're hearing from karmanís
intercom intercom which is revenge
that's a fancy word for revenge now the
head of the IRGC was speaking at
Inkerman and he responded to the crowds
and he said become our response will be
tough it will be decisive and whoever
carried out these attacks they will make
them regret it now javad zarif is again
he's very calm and solemn but he's
pushing for that point that this was a
big mistake
and Iran will respond he said that was a
miscalculation he said that the United
Press United States president was rude
and impolite and he said that his
Secretary of State is even more impolite
and that they have made a grave mistake
and we're hearing that throughout Iran
but normally throughout Iran throughout
the region the regional countries here
are very nervous and people are
increasingly coming to the understanding
that the assassination of Qasem
Soleimani was probably a miscalculation
on behalf of the United States because
now the people on the streets here in
Iran are expecting revenge I expecting a
retaliation and the authorities here
will probably have to oblige in some way